I'm very grateful to you all during
during this horrific year uh the year of
the Russian of Russia Europe becomes
stronger
become stronger thanks to your personal
decisions
and even when there were doubts and
there were perhaps some discussions you
still managed to find the opportunity to
make those decisions together strong
decisions indeed thank you so much for
this and I want to thank you for the
understanding that Europe should not
have the gray zones
that our whole continent should be open
to the European destiny should not have
the destabilization and we understand
that the unity of Europe is the
fundamental way to security
every Europe Cannot Be Imagined without
the free Ukraine and I'm very grateful
to you for the preparation and giving
Ukraine the state to the candidate
status I'm very grateful that we are
looking at the positive results of our
transformation together thank you so
much that we started the negotiations on
membership to the EU and that will
become one more step one more
fundamental brick in our joint security
the European Union has given the support
which is consistent and large scale for
the first time in history
we are very grateful to you for this we
feel that this security interaction has
created a historical
example for any aggressor the example
why the aggression of against European
countries should not take place that's
why this aggression should fail as soon
as possible the stronger we are together
the stronger we have the real European
values going back to uncovering the
church of Ukraine which is now occupied
the stronger we will have European peace
I want to thank you again for
understanding us for supporting us and
understanding how much we need
the possibilities that we need our
children and Munitions the modern tanks
the long-range missiles and modern
fighter jets we are very grateful to you
for giving us this Military Support we
have to enhance the Dynamics of our
cooperation we have to do it faster than
the aggressor that tries to mobilize its
potential I'm very grateful to all the
European nations that understand that
our brave Army our brave soldiers
are fighting against the terror of
Russia with your support